I am standing in a line at Trader Joe's,
and I cannot believe I'm standing in
a line at Trader Joe's because I hate.
Trader Joe's.
Trader Joe's is a bullshit grocery store.
It is a store where I can go in and
get hot dogs and buns, but I can't
get the Doritos and the Diet Coke or
even the aluminum foil that I need to
put on the grill to cook the hot dogs.
This is, this is a grocery store
that requires you to have another
grocery store, and that is bullshit.
You walk in and there's no aisles.
People just mill around like
sheep and look for things The.
The, the registers are all equipped
with this bell because if register
three needs pennies, they ring the bell.
'cause everyone in the goddamn store needs
to know that register three needs pennies.
I hate everything about this store and
the only reason I'm here is 'cause my
daughter, Clara, loves the pizza bites
and Charlie loves the fish sticks and my
wife likes every goddamn thing in this
store, but I'm not even in the store.
I'm outside the store.
In a socially distanced line,
this gathering of people,
because it is May of 2020.
Early in the pandemic.
And the only thing Trader Joe's
does well is they only let a few
people into the store at a time.
So at least it's safe.
So I'm standing in this
line for this store.
I hate for people, I love, and I'm just
trying to keep the peace and I cannot,
'cause there is a woman, three people
in front of me, and she's turned,
she's turned to us and to her audience.
She is masked and she's telling us how
unfair it is that she's being masked.
She cannot stand the fact that she's
being forced to wear this awful thing.
And there's all these
things I wanna say to her.
'cause the one superpower I have in
this world is I know the worst thing to
say to someone to make them feel bad.
I am the person at CVS where if it's a
long line and the woman turns and says,
can you believe how slow this cashier is?
I say in a very loud voice.
Why are you telling me
how slow the cashier is?
She's right up there.
You shouldn't talk behind her back.
And my wife runs and the woman goes
crazy at the Patriots game when, when
the guy in row 17 says, Hey, take your
hat off during the national anthem to
the poor guy in row five who forgot.
I'm the guy who turns
around and says, yeah, ha.
Police.
That is a lot less
disruptive than the hat.
I'm so glad you shouted at the
man during the national anthem.
But my wife has told me I'm going
to get killed someday, and she's
asked me to stop doing this.
So I'm letting the lunatic scream
about the mask and I look at my phone
and then she says the word sacrifice.
She says she's making a great
sacrifice to have to go into the store
and something just snaps with me.
And I look up and I say, excuse me.
My father was drafted and he
had to fight in Vietnam, a
war he did not wanna fight in.
He was exposed to Agent Orange.
He's had four heart attacks and a
heart condition for all his life.
So when I go home today, I'm
gonna tell him about the fucking
hero I saw in the line who made
the sacrifice to wear the mask.
And he's gonna be amazed and she loses her
mind and she starts screaming for the poor
lady in the Trader Joe's line to like.
Have me arrested.
She wants to call the police.
The guy behind me does not help.
He says He didn't verbally abuse you.
He called you a hero.
And that doesn't help.
It doesn't help in any way.
And I realize I've created these
situations that my wife warns me
about, and I realize the only way
to get out of it is I have to leave.
So I tell the Trader Joe's employee,
you don't need to call the police.
I will leave.
I'll come back later as I leave.
She says, that's right.
Walk away.
And it is everything in
me to not turn around.
Yeah, but I don't, I get in the car
and I drive home, and as I'm driving,
I'm thinking about my wife and how she
says this is a bad thing to do, but I
think it's not because there's crazy
people in the world that say terrible
things and good decent people just
have to listen to it all the time.
And I just think.
Maybe I can be the crazy person that says
the right thing to the other crazy people.
So maybe the next time she thinks
about turning around, she'll think
maybe I'm there, and maybe she'll stop.
I'm a social justice
warrior, that's what I think.
I think that until I turn onto
my street and I see our house and
suddenly my body is filled with glee.
I can't wait to tell my wife
what I just did, even though
I know she's gonna be mad.
I am so excited about it and it's
that glee that makes me realize that
I am not a social justice warrior.
I just really love.
To yell at people and make them feel
bad when they deserve to feel bad.
As I'm driving towards my house,
I realize that if the entire world
suddenly became universally kind
and benevolent, I would be upset.
I would.
As I pull into my driveway,
I think I am really no better
than that lunatic in the line.
I. Because I am not shouting at her
because I want the world to change.
I'm shouting at her because I really
like shouting at terrible people.
And if they were to all go away.
That would be a sad day for me, so my wife
is wi, my wife is right as she always is.
I need to shut my damn mouth and move
on in my life and be a better person.
Thank you.